RetroRaconteur here guys
and this past week
We finally got official confirmation that
the Wizarding World of Harry
Potter is getting even bigger
That's right guys a brand new theme park
expansion coming to Universal Orlando
And as someone who hasn't been able to
get down there since they added the
Diagon Alley section
I absolutely cannot wait for this, but
you want to know the most exciting part
We even have a few reliable rumors on the
major attractions and
guys it just sounds so
Incredibly insane if you can't tell I'm
sorry my hype meter, it's
already at a level 10 here
So in this video I'm gonna get you caught
up on the top 10 things you need to know
about the new theme park expansion
To kick things off here
We have the official name of this section
of the park which will be the Wizarding
World of Harry Potter
Ministry of Magic now
This is not an addition to the Diagon
Alley or Hogsmeade sections
It will actually be about two miles south
of Universal Studios
and Islands of Adventure
It's part of a completely new theme park
called Epic Universe set
to open sometime in 2025
Now if you're concerned as to whether they'll
be able to hit that target date or not
You should know things
are already well underway
We can actually see the entrance to the
Ministry of Magic section already
complete with the circular portal and
this whole portal thing is a
Theme across all of the
Epic Universe areas on top
There's a golden statue of a hand holding
what appears to be the Elder Wand
You can also see how these shots compare
to the concept art currently available on
the official website
Here we get a better look at the text across
the top of the portal which features an
iconic line from our favorite headmaster
Albus Dumbledore: For in dreams we enter a
world that is entirely our own
There's also what I'm pretty sure is a
time-turner on top of the portal here
If you've been to any of the Potter theme
parks before you'll know that the
attention to detail and the
respect to the lore is just
Incredible here
So I love the fact that it's like we're
taking a time-turner as
we step into this world
And I think there's a very specific
reason that we'd need to travel back in
time because not only are
we getting the Ministry of
Magic we're also
getting Paris set in the 1920s
This time frame puts us traveling here
during the events of the second fantastic
Beast movie the Crimes of Grindelwald
So essentially as you're walking around
the area everything will look like Paris
all the shops the
restaurants the interactive
experiences all of these will be themed
to what we see during this scene of
Crimes of Grindelwald
This Paris section will also be home to
one of the two major attractions in the
new Wizarding World section
There's an indoor stage show positioned
here, and it's expected to be a show
called LeCirque Arcanus,
which is the name of the traveling circus
in the Crimes of Grindelwald of course
this is where we meet Nagini
Yeah, if you didn't see a fantastic Beasts
This is actually Nagini turns out she's
something called a Maladictus
And then one of the most important
characters in Fantastic Beasts
Credence Barebone
So I'm super curious to see what type of
show that they will put on here
I mean it has to have Wizarding World
elements right it can't just be a regular
circus is it possible
Maybe we'll even see Nagini make an
appearance here the way it plays out in
the movie is that is
kind of one of the biggest
Moments of the show her actually
transforming into the snake now this next
one takes us a bit into
rumor territory because one of the
things that we might get to see in Paris
at least from the outside is the
House of Nicolas Flamel of course fans
know Flamel mostly as being the maker of
the Philosopher's Stone
He also made an appearance
though in Fantastic Beasts
He offered his home to Dumbledore as a
safe house for allies
working to take down Grindelwald
So it seems as if this could be one of
the new areas that has a special
Interaction when you're
using wands sold at the park now
This is already a thing in Islands of
Adventure and Universal Studios
But there are a couple of patents
floating around out there that makes it
seem like the whole interactive wand
experience is going to be
getting an upgrade, in addition to these
new elements at this section of the park.
So we got Paris Ministry of Magic
How exactly do these two connect because
they're not physically in
the same place, of course
Well again
It seems like they definitely had the
lore in mind here as it's being reported
we'll make our way into
the ministry via the floo network
One of my favorite moments in the
movies is the first time we get to see
the British Ministry of Magic on the big
Screen the amazing shots as Harry and
Mr. Weasley step out into the massive atrium
is such an iconic scene
The fountain of magical brethren
Oh, man, I can't wait to
actually see this in person
Of course
This is the scene where Mr. Weasley
accompanies Harry to his trial
after he was charged with using magic
outside of school as
an underage wizard
Now, it's possible the only way to enter the
ministry will be through a
line for what is the feature attraction
of this whole area
The ride inside
of that world. I can't tell you because
it has to be a surprise
And guys this is the
most exciting part for me
Yes, while the movies did a great job showing
parts of the ministry there was so much
more that we didn't get to see
But now with this standout attraction,
there's a chance we'll get to
see some of those areas as well
We don't have the
official name of the ride yet
But there's some pretty reliable rumors
that it will be called Harry Potter and
the Battle at the Ministry
It's expected to feature ride vehicles
similar to the elevators
that we see in the films
You can expect a combination of
animatronics, real sets,
and giant wraparound screens
And it's not even
expected to require 3d glasses
Of course, you know
They gotta have a story play out as we go
through this ride and there was an early
rumor that the story would take place
During a trial for one Dolores Umbridge
set after the Battle of Hogwarts
As the trial is taking place though
Death Eaters break in attempting to free Umbridge
Now, lore fans
You guys will know this might be a bit
strange considering that Umbridge was
never a death eater
That being said, I guess she did align herself
with them pretty closely in the final Potter book
and she certainly didn't
seem to have a problem with
Helping them when they had
taken over the ministry now
I think this could be
interesting don't get me wrong
But if the name is actually Harry Potter
in the Battle at the Ministry, to me
it would make way more sense to have us
play a role in the unforgettable battle
during the climax of Order of the Phoenix
I mean, can you imagine getting a
first-hand look at Dumbledore and
Voldemort battling it out with the giant
fire and water spell effects?
It would be absolute insanity. Of course,
if you're familiar with the storylines on
these rides, they're usually pretty
laid-back pretty loose
They don't always follow a specific
narrative from the book
They try to keep the lore in mind
But with the rides they always want to
make you feel like you're part of the
ride and like you're
actually helping out the characters
So you definitely have to
bend things a little bit here
Regardless of the actual
story for the ride though
I really hope we get to see some of those
amazing areas in the ministry. In addition
to the courtroom area,
this is also the home for numerous
offices like the misuse of magic office,
the auror headquarters, the
Beast Division and of course
The Department of Mysteries.
This is the one that I'm sorry
It has to be included if you remember
from the books the Department of
Mysteries is home to seven different
areas including a room where time
behaves differently, the Hall of Prophecy,
There's the brain room and even the death
chamber, which is the location of the
mysterious veil that
Sirius falls through
Now, it's probably unrealistic, I know, that
we'll get to see all of
those sections during a ride
that's likely just to be a few minutes
But the patents for the ride do give me
hope that we could see quite a few of them.
The elevator itself should be able
to move both vertically, horizontally, and
also turn in any direction
So we could actually rotate between just
a few real world floors and directions
But all of the props and projections
could swap out as we move. So with this
there's definitely a chance that we could
get to see quite a few of the ministry
floors in this ride. Now before we get to
another big rumor about what they might
be adding next to the wizarding world
It's important to know it's not the only
new section here epic universe will also
be home to a gorgeous new
land called Celestial Park,
Dark Universe, which will be home to all of
Universal's horror creatures, a How To
Train Your Dragon themed area,
which looks phenomenal
and for all my fellow gamers out there
Super Nintendo World
This one's gonna feature an augmented
reality ride themed to Mario Kart a
Donkey Kong themed coaster and a slower
paced ride for the little
ones featuring Yoshi. As far as where you
can actually stay there are not one
but three new hotels that will be opening
near epic universe in
fact the Grand Helios hotel,
which will have 500 guest rooms is
actually located inside the epic universe
park and as someone who has been to
Universal Orlando before even though
It will definitely cost
you more to stay on site
I think the benefits more than makeup for
it the premier hotels there all include
free access to the Universal Express Pass,
which basically lets you skip the lines
some of the most
popular rides in the park.
Now I do want to point out
we don't have the details yet on how this
will work specifically with epic universe
I think you can probably expect though
that they're gonna have a similar system
to what's already in place for Universal
Studios and islands of adventure
All right if that's not enough for the
Wizarding World fans
There are already rumors that epic
universe will see a new Wizarding World
edition soon after the park opens
There's a pretty large area of land just
next to the Ministry of Magic section and
one of the early rumors again
I have to stress rumor here so far a lot
of these rumors have
actually ended up being right
But this one says that we'll be taking
floo powder yet again this time though
We're gonna be transported directly to
Hogwarts into the Great Hall
Here, we would get to enjoy an elaborate dining
experience along with storytelling
elements that would - wait for it -
play out on the ceiling as
you dine. Like, oh my goodness
Yes, yes
Please make this happen Universal and
even though this may be a little odd
considering that the Hogwarts castle is
actually at the Islands
Of Adventure section of the park, hey you
gotta do what you gotta do right?
Space is limited because it's magical world
We can use something like floo powder to
explain it perfectly
in a lore accurate way
I love it. And even though we are so many
years removed from the Harry Potter
series originally releasing the fandom
doesn't appear to be
slowing down anytime soon. If you guys
didn't hear a Harry Potter TV show,
a reboot of the original seven book story
is happening and it's coming to max
formerly known as HBO max
You didn't know that? Well guess what,
I already got all the details that you need
to know right here
Check out that video next!
Guys, thank you so much for your support,
especially to our House Raconteur Members
As always thank you all so much
for watching. I'll talk to you again soon